good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday hope
everyone had an amazing refreshing
rejuvenating and relaxing weekend hey
Jax how you doing I'm doing good my
weekend was all of those things I think
except for the fact that I pulled my
back out on Friday night into Saturday
morning in my Slumber and it's still not
a hundred percent and like trying to be
a mom with a tweaked neck and back is
really challenging and I'm just like
Zoolander like I can't turn all the way
Zach keeps making fun of me but it's
also forcing my posture to be impeccable
like I've just been sitting like this
because I can't move my neck down and
that's really
took over my weekend there are honestly
few things worse in this life than
throwing your back out not only is it
Beyond painful but you're also useless
useless like on Saturday I really
couldn't like pick Harry up out of the
crib uh I could hold him like sometimes
but really useless yesterday was better
it just hurts but you gotta power
through
no I [ __ ] like
some of the lowest moments of my life
are when my back is thrown out and I
keep forgetting to take Advil you know
I'm just so busy like I should have
taken it this morning I should have
taken it last night and I just keep
forgetting so I'm just in pain
I'm so sorry that that happened to you
but you know what the lord giveth the
lord taketh away as well because the
lord giveth on Thursday night at least
for me I haven't even spoken to you
about this I got home from my show in
Red Bank which was amazing thank you to
everyone who showed up
um and my YouTube plaque had arrived has
yours arrived yet no
you know with this move you are like a
couple days behind shipping wise like
when I got my Jessica Simpson roller
skates from Jessica Simpson herself
yours came like a few days later yeah oh
that's so rough well I'm glad you got
yours first I'm and I'm very patient as
a person so if anyone has to be on the
delay I'm glad that it's me I saw that
you got yours but I wasn't even like
where is mine like I know mine will be
here it will you have to trust in the
universe and trust in you trust yes that
your packages will be delivered yeah so
we got our 100 000 subscribers YouTube
plaque it was a huge
a huge moment it wasn't one of those
things that you anticipated and then it
finally happens and it's like I keep
walking back into the living room
looking at it marveling at us at our
business at our Mogul energy and it's
just a constant reminder and once I have
it framed and hung on my wall it will be
a constant reminder that like we are
amazing yeah that's always nice to be
reminded of that also we keep we
actually stopped trying to remember to
say this on the show but I just want to
um mention something that a few weeks
ago we hit a different Milestone of 900
episodes
oh I know we can't forget it the day
that it was the 900th like right after
we remembered and we were like [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh but we are in the 900s which
means that in a few months we will have
our 1 000th episode and I don't know
what happens once you've done a thousand
episodes of a podcast like does someone
tape your mouth shut right I look
forward to finding out and it's just
[ __ ] crazy I think once you hit a
thousand episodes you automatically get
canceled no I think that happens at like
100 like the first 50. if you can
survive like the first 50
I am curious though
um
who else
in the podcasting space has hit a
thousand episodes
yeah he has because his episodes are
numbered and they're like 1 300. right
right so I'm I'm wondering who else
because most people do weekly yeah and
it would have to be someone who's been
around doing this for really for years
because Joe Rogan started in 2011. what
about the daily
they're always like above us in the
charts and it makes me hate the New York
Times that's what makes you hate the New
York Times and the anti-Semitism for
sure that that'll do it but honestly the
charts it's number of episodes
1598. damn okay I think it's definitely
a very short
list and yes I hope one day where Hashem
will be on it yeah that's very exciting
for us so sorry we didn't get to
acknowledge the Milestone with you know
a party maybe some balloons like we did
our 700th episode we also forgot to
acknowledge our 800. yeah we're just
weird about like what we choose to
acknowledge 700 because we realized it
the day before we got right it's not
it's not even a choice it's just
circumstance yeah but I do think once we
hit a thousand and it will be in a while
because we still have to do 100 episodes
which takes us about I think five months
um once we hit a thousand I really we
should have a party we're like one of
those sitcoms that hits 100 episodes you
know oh my God totally and then they get
syndicated and they all get a cake yeah
and they all get big checks I guess I
guess maybe we should get ourselves
cakes
I'll send you one you send me one
um so other than that like my whole
weekend kind of revolved around the
plaque you know I was like what does the
plaque want to do today does the plaque
want to go out to lunch does the black
want to go shopping what did the term
want to do just lay in bed and so I had
no choice I laid in bed the whole
weekend I read I watched TV it was very
relaxing I did not leave my house until
yesterday
um and that's was simply out of
necessity because I'm going on a trip
for Labor Day weekend and your girly has
not one thing to wear and so I had to
get some clothing and then I got home
and something I've been meaning to do
for like a really long time I did which
was clean out my closet
and I'm I'm really good about like
cleaning out my closet every couple of
months this time I had waited like so
long when I tell you I felt like I got
out of a soul cycle class when I was
done like driplets of sweat dripping
down my face neck ass crack I got like
10 garbage bags full of donations it
felt so good and now I walk into my
closet and I feel Joy I really do I love
that I'm so happy for you thank you and
everyone was like you're organizing and
cleaning out because you're moving
no I'm not you guys don't push her don't
push her you won't like what you're
gonna see you have to know I feel like
by now you you know our personalities
are predilections predilection and you
guys have to know not to push Claudia
she has to come to everything on her own
I couldn't push her into watching
Downton Abbey I couldn't push her into
reading I just have to make a light
suggestion and let the chips fall where
they know where they may totally so no
plans currently just I appreciate an
organized home you know that we know
sweeper never stops the sweeper never
stops like oh you like something you
better watch it because I'm gonna throw
it out if I don't like it yeah no oh you
didn't use it for five minutes garbage
yeah no that's what I do oh you haven't
worn the shirt in a week probably better
off donating I don't need it you don't
need it
um
I had one more thing to say well first
of all we have such a it's going to be a
nice long oh my God because literally
the world did not stop turning there's
so much I actually had to bump a story
till tomorrow yeah which is good there
was a lot of like you know JV stories
that will be for tomorrow's episode if
nothing else comes up but there's so
much I actually I think it was Liz hype
posted on her Instagram story that like
the publicists got back to work this
week and he's back from summer break
everyone's back from summer break
there's stories and our cup runneth over
I'm so excited and it's Monday which
means everyone is going to be able to
unburden themselves in the UB segment
and last night was the second episode of
House of the Dragon The Game of Thrones
prequel I watched it and of course I
love watching it but I love watching it
with the anticipation of knowing we're
gonna slay this recap yeah I just want
to say now that we're talking about it
two things like you were very right
about one thing and then I was right
about one thing but I was very wrong
about something I was wrong about Otto
Hightower nefarious nefarious as [ __ ] I
don't know why last episode I thought
that he like was fine I thought he was
neutral like not what was I right about
you were right that Damon actually might
be
one of the good ones
he's Jackie he's like Josh and Ben good
guys
sing a girl one
the kind you find when you don't even
look everybody wants a good one he's
good all the time tell him he's one of
the good ones and he's a man foreign
that was not your best I'm gonna be
honest I feel like Gabby Barrett and I
don't have the same pitch what can you
do
speaking of good guys I there's a new
episode of Josh and Ben's podcast and
there's like some drama like leave it to
them second episode like starting drama
um because as last week we teased there
was like a really big interview coming
up just go listen to the episode they
explained it in the beginning and then
they just do like a funny episode but
there's drama yeah
big drama big drama early drama
drama that hurts
yeah
I wasn't sure if you were going to say
that I was
yourself will stop teasing the drama and
just go listen to it when you're done
with this but you're going to want to
listen to today's episode so anyways
yeah back to before I was singing
you were right that Damon actually might
be like the good one and maybe the king
and his peeps like are the nefarious
actors here and I was right that Alice
didn't Allison they didn't have sex that
night it was they were laying the
foundation which is exactly what
happened yeah I don't want to respond
because then we'll get into the whole
thing and that will be for the TV recap
after the past five
um so if there's nothing else you want
to say I suggest we just dive in because
there is a litany look at me SAT Word
Litany of things we need to discuss most
importantly Taylor's album
notably Kelsea ballerini yeah I just
wanted to discuss one more thing if I
may sure and it's something that I'm
looking at right now which is that
you're wearing a seamla
no I'm not buying a romper oh really it
looks like a seamlove from where I'm
sitting for those who don't know seamla
is dressed in Hebrew and Jackie refers
to use the word dress ever since she
rediscovered the word seamless just
because there's something about like
when you're ready it's so feminine
seamless when you're wearing a dress
like it's just a seamless no this isn't
a seamless it's a romper from show me
your MooMoo I actually placed an order
show me your movie last night because I
decided to bloom where I'm planted and
get close up at me okay so I have like
had a Renaissance recently with show me
your memo this is not sponsored not at
all I paid full price I don't even think
honey picked up a code for me well um
they sent me like so much new clothing
for free and the sweater I wore last
week that said howdy that everyone was
like obsessed with is show me your Momo
it's sold out this Romper show me your
MooMoo and honestly
I think it's important to mention and
promote brands that make cute [ __ ] not
ugly [ __ ] because everyone's making ugly
[ __ ] that makes [ __ ] that is good
quality with like a decent price it's a
little expensive but it's decent and
brands that have a normal range of sizes
like so I'm always here I'm gonna I'm
gonna promote a brand that does that
even though I don't benefit from it at
all even though I do get free clothes
yeah no that's really nice I didn't know
like you got free clothes but you know
what I'm happy you get what you pay for
and um too
I'm looking forward to receiving my
order that I literally placed last night
so it's such a clinky dink and that's
like that was a real impetus for me to
clean out my closet because they sent me
such nice things I'm like these things
deserve a nice place to lay yeah the
rule general rule of thumb though I
personally don't stick to it is after
every new piece of clothing you should
remove a piece of clothing from your
closet that you don't wear and donate it
so that you never have like
right now your closet is full I'm sure
so you then you start stuffing stuff the
more you get but you really don't wear
everything in your closet so if you
could find a way to remove something for
every new thing you would remain your
equilibrium would be intact okay that
literally never occurred to me and I'm
going to do that that's so smart thanks
and by the way what I do is when I clean
out my closet I make I do I clean out so
big that I have space because then I get
new clothing and I'm like all right now
I can withstand the things that I get
you know we're about to go into fall I'm
going to need sweaters you know you're
gonna need sweaters
and I think I'm gonna wear this hat to
the party tonight you know you should
um it's really yeah sharp don't you
think you know black wait I had
something else is this yours pink I'm so
musical today you are you're sounding
like me and now I really understand why
it's annoying I got bit with the bug oh
[Music]
that I wanted to say but I cannot
remember
I remember okay
I started we are the brennans
why because Margo recommended it to me
then I went on Goodreads I saw you gave
it five stars I did yes oh I must have
been hit over the head oh my God what a
piece of [ __ ] literally okay so this
just a little backstory this was our
redheads book actually one year ago to
date it was a snitch's choice and
considering it was a snitch's choice we
actually all we we all enjoyed it and we
liked it I don't know why I gave it five
stars it's kind of was like Dreadful but
fine positively Dreadful first of all
give me a group of more unlikable
characters there was not one and I got
through thirty percent and that's when I
decided to you know protect my piece and
not finish it
literally give me one character who I
could even remotely identify with now
everyone was just out here making bad
decisions financially bad decisions
personally bad decisions romantically
drinking and driving like literally
hated every minute of every word I read
yeah it's I wouldn't have recommended it
for you it was a good book for the
redheads because there was like a lot of
themes and characters and story lines to
dissect and because it was a departure
for the snitch which we always encourage
encourage of course speaking of which
this month's book episode drops on
Thursday we are recording tomorrow we
read
um Everything I Know About Love by Dolly
alderton I'm about 60 in and I think you
would like that it's Dolly's Memoir and
it's really it not every moment every
story I'm obsessed with but she really
like captures something about
your 20s that I'm really enjoying and
it's making me nostalgic but not
enough not missing those days whatsoever
yeah well when I had to uh burn my
Kindle after reading we are the brennans
then I went into something safe which
was like a spicy rom-com and it was
recommended to me and it has a sequel so
I just want to say it's called a not so
meat cute and then the sequel is called
so not meant to be and don't be
dissuaded by the titles and the the
cover art it's like really corny they're
both so cute so funny and like what I
didn't expect like I know what I'm gonna
get from a book you know this one is
going to give me Thriller this one's
gonna give me porn this one's gonna make
me laugh so I was not expecting the porn
book to make me cackle so many times
like I especially last night in the
sequel I was reading something so funny
the writer is like weirdly very funny I
love that and it's just a nice layer to
like a cute romantic comedy Vibe I have
been cackling like there's a few moments
in each book that like genuinely make me
belly laugh which is really hard to make
me laugh in a book
yeah oh but there's nothing better
there's nothing better mostly I only
really laugh at celebrity Memoirs yeah I
was thinking like Tom sugura made me
laugh Claudia ashrae made me laugh of
course she does uh Gary Genetti makes me
laugh Sophie kinsella makes me laugh you
still haven't read one so if he can sell
a book no read one
it's just one of those things you know
I'll read it in five years yeah and be
like have you read it and then I'll
start like a Sophie kinsella Instagram
fan page literally but you know what I
won't push you
I know you and I love how you are and
everything about you so I'll lightly
suggest it and move on and not get too
wrapped up in it cool cool I'll get
there yeah you always do
I let's also talk about the week this
week uh it's Labor Day so there is no
show Friday or Monday
um because I will be enjoying my time in
Turks and Caicos and you should come and
see me on your way home oh you know what
I should I should I think that would be
right
okay I'll think about it and I know your
shows would allow it right so my shows
like one tracker just quickly promote
September 17th and 18th I will be in the
Pacific Northwest I would love to see
all of my pnw toasters Seattle and
Portland the 17th and 18th tickets
available at girl with no job.com tour
great I'm so excited for that
um obviously construction workers for
guange tour are excited about it too and
now I think we've adequately plugged
everything I think so what else did I do
I just I was honestly in back breaking
pain this weekend and I was reading for
the redhead so please you guys it's
never too late to become a redhead we're
kind of like taking over I can't really
explain what's going on with the
redheads but I also feel like books in
general plus like Kindles are having a
Renaissance and the redheads are just
like
kind of leading the charge so and by the
way I feel like you I successfully got
someone to read who
Abe okay he I a couple months ago I was
like you have to buy a Kindle and so he
bought one he's like I really want to
get into reading and then he opened it
and he was like this is a Kindle like
and you know what he like I know what he
meant like the interface is like
literally from 1997 like yeah the store
and he was like not into it but he went
um this weekend to Israel it's his
birthday happy birthday Abe and he was
like I'm gonna bring the Kindle suggest
a couple books for me so I suggested
luckiest girl because he said I want
like certain types so I said luckiest
girl alive then I said Verity because he
wanted like a murder mystery Vibes and I
do feel like he'll appreciate the little
you know porn elements and then I
recommended red white and royal blue and
so on the good right yeah and then you
should read that
okay I've told you so many times I think
you would like it okay I'll add it to my
thing well he read luckiest girl live on
the plane and I think when I told him
that Mila Kunis was making a movie out
of it he like thought it was like cool
you know yeah and he loved it like
Beyond loved and it really it felt so
good it feels so good I'm I think book
recommendations are more personal than
food more personal than comedy when I
recommend a book to someone like I
really
I follow up I'm like did you read the
book what did you think about the book
like I'm I I recommended it for you I
didn't recommend it to everyone right
sometimes I read a book and I'm like
Kristen would love this book yes yes I
know what you mean she knows that like I
I take it really seriously so I think
everyone who I like I'm like you have to
read this book they eventually do
yeah and it feels good when somebody
like takes your recommendation and then
loves it and I feel like I did a good I
don't really I get asked for
recommendations from people in my life
like on Instagram I'll recommend like a
good porn book but other than that like
no one really asks for tailored selects
and I felt really good I actually had
two good tailored selects moments like
this past week Stasi has gone into
reading too and she's such a historical
fiction girly she's her area focuses a
little uh before my time but I've read
some books in in her beat and I
recommended like two books to her that
she loved and then also Shannon read
that Titanic book that um because she
was saying like her and her friend
Taylor became obsessed with the Titanic
so I was like if you read this book
you'll have no further questions and she
listens to books on tape which is just
something cute about her books on tape
are you 97 years old she does the audio
audiobook okay yeah she does the
audiobook and she read that Titanic one
and she really enjoyed it so books on
tape that is literally really such a
throwback throwback you have a bunch of
tape I do have a book on tape girl with
no job.com
I do feel sad though that like both for
both of us like our Renaissance with
reading came long after the time where
like borders Barnes and Noble were like
these social because I could see
spending a Sunday rainy afternoon
cuddled up at a Barnes and Noble with
like a Starbucks like that is something
I would do and that was totally a thing
when we were like nine and I'm like
you're not gonna get me to spend my
weekend at a [ __ ] bookstore and it's
just sad that we missed that yeah also I
was with a friend yesterday and she was
telling me how like to if you go to the
library I know a lot of people already
know this but a lot of people don't if
you go to your local library and get a
library card which is free and like we
need a library Renaissance in general
100 then you download an app called
Libby and you plug in your library card
information and you can read all these
books for free you just borrow them a
lot of the more popular books do have a
wait list but like instead of buying
books on Amazon all the time like if you
just get a library card download Libby
it connects to your Kindle you can be
borrowing books for free from the
library no for sure and libraries sound
so quaint when it's you know in your
town yeah you're not going to the New
York Public Library it's not a safe
haven it's not that's exactly what I
said it's a public restroom now that I
live in Suburbia like the library sounds
cute but I wouldn't have been heading
down to the New York Public Library
before no I had to and it's romanticized
of course Sex in the City and you see
the outside it's so gorgeous but what
you don't actually know is like that's
not really the library like the actual
library with a stock of books is across
the street and it's forlorn it's like an
old ass government building literally
it's my friend Rachel's dad used to call
it the pubic library because it's
literally disgusting yeah it's forlorn
so it's forlorn it's abandoned it's
disgusting yeah no I know why I
personally hadn't gone to the library
recently but now that I don't live in
New York maybe I will and not to get
political but our libraries paid for by
taxpayer dollars I think so
so we're paying like super high taxes
here for things like that gorgeous
libraries hospitals things like that
right yeah exactly the hospitals are
good the food Library
roads yeah no honestly if you want to
hear my true thoughts on taxes go watch
my comedy special just Grace Queen
available on Amazon Prime it's all in
there it's all in there like honestly I
do believe my groundbreaking you know
earth-shattering special put a Target on
my back for the IRS honestly yeah but
good thing you've got your [ __ ] together
oh I pay I pay and I pay and I pay you
know what I'm thinking I feel like we
recently have so many new
like so many new toasters so many new
listeners and I don't know if all of
them know that you actually have a
comedy special from your first tour no I
know to watch like if you Claudius and
her not like other girls tour right now
which is amazing and it's so [ __ ]
funny and hopefully one day we will all
be able to watch it on our televisions
but her last tour that she did right
before kovid the dirty jeans tour she
did a comedy special and you can watch
it on Amazon and it's so fun premium so
whenever I'm on my stories and I'll
share like somebody read my book or
somebody's like you know watching my
special I'll always share it you know
girls got to promote and I've been
getting so many messages recently like
wait you have a book wait what's this
comedy special
um and I guess that's just the power of
tick tock because we've literally gotten
so many new followers and listeners
which we're so grateful for welcome yes
I have a book A Memoir that just came
out it hit the New York Times
bestsellers list number [ __ ] 12. and
number two number 12 number 12
yourselves
laughs
and before this tour I was on my first
tour which was the dirty jeans tour and
I recorded that special and it's on
Amazon Prime it's called disgrace queen
and I believe it's free yes so check it
out once you're done listening to this
and then good guys of course Elizabeth
dreams like probably a podcast exactly
then watch Claudia then and only that oh
wait don't forget about patreon
into all 250 episodes that we've ever
done on patreon and then you can watch
Claudia's special
okay are you trying to get people to
watch my special or not no I am I just
want them to be fully immersed prepared
in TNN Universe in TNN culture TNN
things
okay we actually relate together because
we have a long [ __ ] show we do so
without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
Clinique if you have dark spots it can
often feel like a vicious cycle as soon
as one Fades another pops up but you can
break the cycle with the Clinique Even
Better clinical dark spot interrupter
this powerful serum works on melon and
Rich to fair skin and helps physically
correct dark spots such as acne marks
while protecting from future
discoloration so 94 of people
demonstrated an improvement in Radiance
and visible skin tone including acne
marks in eight weeks you can see a 39
visible reduction in dark spots in 12
weeks if you suffer from dark spots and
you know it's literally one of the most
annoying things on the planet they are
really difficult to get rid of and then
once you do successfully get rid of
another one like
there's another one right next door you
know
um and Clinique has is a brand that you
can totally trust I've used makeup
skincare from them for years and their
dark spot interrupter is a serum that
genuinely works
they also have
um a damage eraser which is a
brightening complex that is more
concentrated with boosted technology to
deliver dramatic brightening results but
it's gentle enough for all skin types
their brightening serum works on all
different types of complexions whether
you have melanin Rich skin fair skin
it's going to help you improve uneven
skin tone and interrupt the look of
future dark spots it's free of oil
generated alcohol SLS sulfates parabens
flatulates fragrance it's oil free it's
non-acnegenic and it's a fast absorbing
serum and it's dermatologist developed
you can get even better clinical dark
spot interrupter today when you go to
clinique.com so the even better better
clinical start oh my God even better
clinical dark spot interrupter is
available at clinique.com today's
episode is also brought to you by little
spoon summer's coming to an end that
means the busy season back to school and
regular life chaos is coming our way
what's one way to make your life a
little easier little spoon a One-Stop
shop for healthy easy meal time and
snack time for your baby toddler and big
kid delivered right to your door with
fresh organic baby food for every stage
Toddlers and kids meals that even picky
eaters love and healthy snack time with
their new smoothie line little spoon has
you covered so when you have a bunch of
kids different ages grocery store
shopping can a be really expensive and
like so stressful and chaotic because
your kids are all at different levels
eating different things and so much of
the stuff on the Shelf is so processed
and it's not the quality of nutrition
you want for your kids but little spoon
makes everything fresh and they use
absolutely nothing artificial it's just
like homemade it's all delivered to your
door and it's ready in seconds pop your
meals in the fridge or the freezer and
use them whenever you're ready it's that
easy so they're nutritionally balanced
they're free of junk they're super
delicious and you're setting your kid up
for a lifetime of health and the
smoothies have made snack time really
easier I'm sure you guys remember when
you were a kid like choosing a snack is
probably one of the hardest things about
being a kid but little spoon is taking
that away from you because their
smoothies are so good and your kids are
going to love them also and the best
I've now been getting into solids with
rolled everyone is telling me obviously
about little spoon which we know and I
know like Taylor loves it and I'm so
excited I'm like so close to being able
to give him all of those things and I'm
like can't it's just gonna take stress
off oh my God I can't wait
the best part is that the price is just
kids meals under six dollars and baby
food and smoothie snacks under three
dollars so it makes trying little spoon
really easy make this year's chaos a
little more manageable with time saving
delicious and healthy meals that you can
feel good about enter code toast at
checkout to get 50 off your first little
spoon order that's 50 off your first
little spoon order with the code toast
at checkout thank you yeah well gum what
can I say except Taylor Swift announced
a new album called Midnight after her
bmas 2022 speech so first two stories
are kind of Blended together we're gonna
try and break it down
VMAs were on last night who knew but you
know what a lot of news came out from
them a lot of actual real stars there
was star power there there was and
Taylor Swift accepted an award
um and during her acceptance speech she
announced that she has a new album
coming out in October she said quote I
thought it might be a fun moment to tell
you that my brand new album comes out
October 21st I will tell you more at
midnight and then at midnight she posted
on her Instagram Said album called
midnights she said midnights the stories
of 13 sleepless nights scattered
throughout my life will be out October
21st meet me at midnight
in the Instagram post it has this bit of
text I'm hoping we can break it down and
then we'll also break down October 21st
we lie awake in love and in fear in
turmoil and in tears we stare at walls
and drink until they speak back we twist
in our self-made cages and pray that we
aren't right this minute about to make
some faithful life-altering mistake this
is a collection of Music written in the
middle of the night a journey through
Terrors and sweet dreams the floors we
pace and the demons we Face Damon for
all of us who have tossed and turned and
decided to keep the lanterns lit and go
searching hoping that we just maybe when
the clock strikes 12 we'll meet
ourselves midnights the stories of 13
sleepless nights scattered throughout my
life will be on October 21st meet me at
midnight
okay so first of all I think there was a
lot of you know speculation from the
swifties like are we gonna get another
re-recording soon or is the next thing
we get going to be original music and I
would have been happy for either but I
obviously am happier that it's new music
because it's been a really long time
since since Evermore
I love the concept of this first of all
like relatable Queen like who else who
like everyone is up at night like
thinking about their worst fears things
going on in their life and I'm sure for
Taylor like relatable it happens to her
all the time and I think it's
interesting that each song is like a
different night based on you know
whatever was going through her life at
that point and I'm curious if like
and I'm sure we will be able to decipher
like what each song is about not
everyone because we don't know
everything that goes on in her life but
I'm sure that like you know one of the
songs will be like the night she met Joe
or something like and we'll be able to
decide or maybe like and since she
announced it at the VMAs I have to
imagine perhaps there's one song about
after you know what kept her up that
night after the VMAs with Kanye yeah
that's so true also it will probably be
harder because I feel like every album
she puts out is like a moment in time
it's like oh this past year and a half
and here's how I felt about it and then
we just have to examine a year and a
half this will be like examining her
whole life her whole life if anyone can
figure out the Swifty code it's the
swifties and so I'm not worried and I
know she will give us enough Easter eggs
to put it together
and you know now that we've officially
entered a new era I do feel as though
everything she wears now is indicative
of what the vibe of the album will be
and Lasting at the VMAs she looked so
gorgeous she was wearing this Crystal it
was honestly it was giving Kendall
Jenner at the Met Gala it was really
similar
um and I'm sorry you know to have
brought that up but she looked so
beautiful and then at the after party I
didn't even think she could do better
than she did at the VMAs and she did she
was wearing this like blue Starry Romper
with like this furry shawl it was So
Glamorous it was honestly both outfits
were giving kind of that Wildest Dreams
aesthetic from the music video like old
Hollywood very glamorous red lip yeah
but she is old Hollywood that is her
aesthetic like always aside from when
she's like putting on a different one
um that hasn't been her aesthetic for a
really long time yeah I would love her
we got like really bright colors oh yeah
with Evermore we got like Cottage core
right so perhaps you know this is a a
return to the tailor of yore the tailor
of your I'm very excited for everyone
for myself I'm excited for new music I
wonder what the vibe will be I feel like
it's still going to be in this vein of
like
emo singer songwriter it's not going to
be the pop no yeah even though she did
say like in the description it's both
nightmares and dreams so I feel like
some of them will be like very Whimsical
very dreamy and others will be maybe you
know more dark
but again like what's the genre that's
the thing with Taylor like you never
know what you're gonna get because one
album is country one album's alternative
one album is pop like what is it it's
cross genre and that's why we stand our
talented Queen but it does make it
difficult to have expectations yeah I
don't know why I thought October 21st
was sooner than now I'm realizing it's
two months and I just kind of hate that
like this whole you know lead up
but the thing about Taylor is like she's
so traditional the way she does music is
the way people have been doing music for
the last 20 years and I think a lot of
artists have changed that you know they
do uh surprise albums like but she's
like the old school she did you guys
album for
folklore current again
for folklore yeah well that was because
we were desperate and she was um it was
a global crisis and she was being
helpful and we're grateful yeah we are
great but for the most part she does
that old school way like lots of press
one or two singles like one or two music
videos right people don't really do that
anymore they just drop works of art
entirely but she goes like the Old
School radio route yeah that's very true
I mean it's fine and the time will fly
oh it's annoying it's [ __ ] annoying
it is annoying you know what I was
thinking about this morning remember
when she dropped Evermore and like in
the art it still said like Weathervane
or whatever no not Weathervane wood Veil
wood Veil
and everyone was like oh my God third
album It's a triplets and they were like
oh no we forgot to take it out that was
like the the fake title of the album
when we were working on the artwork and
it's like
really relatable people worked on this
and you forgot you just left it
relatable
relatable even Taylor Swift makes
mistakes no I know but
that was crazy and people still think
that like there's a conspiracy there and
it was meant to be there and like she's
lying about it being a mistake no I I
like that there is a third sister album
to Folklore and Evermore titled Woodvale
um especially like there's so many Clues
you know when she released those
cardigans for the song cardigan it had
three stars on it and they were like
it's emblematic of each album yeah now
we also need to talk about the fact that
midnights is coming out on October 21st
which is Kim Kardashian's birthday
doesn't which means nothing like people
are so annoying because first of all if
you know anything about Taylor you know
that the dates that she releases her
music on have to mean something she's
you know what she is is she Jewish
because she's very into gamatria
Gematria yeah for those who don't know
like in Hebrew and like this is like a
Biblical thing each letter in the Hebrew
alphabet is associated with a number so
sometimes like a word will equal
um like for example okay the word Hai
which means life in Judaism like life is
significant fight with the number 18
like everyone knows 18 is a lucky number
in Judaism because it means life and
that's because Hai is two letters
is eight and the yud is ten but also it
speaks ten think about it like a is one
B is two right C is three and like all
the way till z is 26. so each letter has
a corresponding number and then the
letters but does it go does it go
numerical I feel like after 10 it
becomes weird or maybe after 20. no I
mean I haven't learned about Chan
forever but yeah but what's so weird
that you mentioned that I saw a post on
my Instagram today that was Gematria but
English Gematria from Peloton memes and
so it says if a is a b c d e equals one
two three four five then knowledge the
letters of knowledge equal 96
hard work equals 98 both are important
but fall just short of a hundred percent
but the word attitude equals a hundred
percent okay they're just trying to get
you to Peloton but no it's Peloton memes
it's not the corporate account well
honestly gematri is like such a
throwback it brings me back to like
literally third grade learning about
tree and like not understanding it at
all I'm like well are they numbers or
letters they're both but Taylor is like
a Jewish queen with the gamatria so
October 21st is the date Taylor's lucky
number is 13.
um so 10 21 which is the date one zero
two and one is uh sorry 10 and 21 is
wait yeah ten two and one is 13. so they
always have to mean something and you
have to release music on a Friday so
there are limited options for Taylor
when it comes to Fridays in a year which
numbers also have meaning and lines with
her calendar and she loves October yeah
sad girl Autumn like she loves so I
think it literally has nothing to do
with Kim and I will believe that until
she gives me a reason to believe that it
does have anything to do with Kim I
think it has nothing to do with Kim as
she's told us she wants nothing to do
with this narrative I can't imagine
she's doing things to keep her in like
the new cycle with Kim Kardashian I'm
sure like I'd
I would be shocked if she even knew
about this and I'm sure if she didn't
she's like annoyed today that oh that's
what people are taking away from this
that they think I did right in his
birthday
but you know what it does actually make
me feel really bad for Kim
because
Kim can't enjoy the musical stylings of
Taylor Swift which just sucks because
there's really something for everyone in
Taylor Swift's catalog and whatever
music you're into whatever you listen to
I think everyone pretty much agrees
unless you're like so stubborn that like
there is a place in Taylor Taylor's
discography for you no and also like we
know Kim was a fan of Taylor she has
that before iconic video saying she
loves love story love story and then
she's watching Taylor on Twitter but I
actually think there are so many people
who I like really hate and I just find a
way to put it out of my mind and listen
to their music and I feel like when Kim
is like in the gym or whatever and we've
heard like their music sometimes in the
back Kim Taylor's music in the
background of some people's Instagram
stories I feel like she can put it out
of her head
like full Taylor Swift albums but when
it comes on and she's like in the mood
she's able to just enjoy the music by
the way I know what you mean like there
are people who I hate so much but like
their music Sorry like it slaps I'm
going to listen to it anyway but there
are also people that I don't have
personal beef with that you know what I
mean but there's also people that I hate
and I actually can't listen to their
music anymore
I understand
for Kim I I don't know if it's the same
comparison just because like this is
personal it's not like just hating
someone from afar yeah that's true
so um I hope I really do hope that Kim
is letting herself enjoy the musical
stylings of Taylor Swift because it's
such a it's such a pleasure it's a
privilege yeah and so I'm excited that
we all have this took forward too and
Taylor looked I just want to say like so
spectacular we never get to see her and
like we're just so desperate for like
little crumbs and she gave us a whole
ass piece of bread last night and she
looked amazing and I love her so much
and it was so fabulous to see her really
and we're gonna get to see a lot more of
her and this is obviously her era is
clearly very sparkly midnight you know
disco ball is what I'm getting and I
think there'll be a lot more where this
came from so get excited and the artwork
was very cool very edgy very cool
cute okay our next story a little more
VMAs news for me I think it was like the
headline from the evening even though I
didn't watch the animes I barely kept up
with like the looks or anything but
Addison Ray's mom and young Grady kissed
on the 2022 MTV VMAs red carpet
I think um I know like a decent amount
about this if you want me to give you
like a little back story okay please
so you know Addison Ray's dad has been
out here embarrassing himself and his
family over the last couple of weeks
and it all really started with like him
making these crazy videos about young
gravy and the reason why he was doing
that was because young gravy was like
doing press basically saying like he
thinks Sherry is everything of the sort
like he wants to date her like he was
being very public about like how he's
really into Sherry and Monty who's
Sherry's ex-husband I think they're
probably I don't know if they're
divorced yet
um And Addison's dad made all these
videos like saying how disrespectful it
was even though like he recently was
exposed for literally cheating on the
mother of his children and his wife
so it it started this weird beef between
young gravy and Monty Lopez and honestly
Sherry never even acknowledged it like
but then there were some other weirdness
with Addison unfollowing her mom Addison
Addison's mom tweeting like I'm
heartbroken yada yada mothers will
understand and so it's been unclear like
what's going on between Addison and her
mom but we're all pretty sure Addison is
not talking to her dad because he's
acting like a [ __ ] animal like a
three-year-old on social media
so then after all of this last night
young gravy shows up on the red carpet
with Sherry as his date
and it's so bizarre he's 26 she's in her
40s I am fairly certain they're not
dating
um I think that like
young gravy was more than happy to be
used as a pawn and Sherry Ray's divorce
drama like her ex-husband has been so
embarrassing like texting 20 year olds
put it posting these disgusting videos
then hanging out with Ava Louise who is
obviously Addison's like arch nemesis
like
doing all of these things to embarrass
Sherry to embarrass Addison and I think
Sherry and young gravy used last night's
Red Carpet as like a moment to get back
at him I really don't think that they're
dating even though they kissed on the
red carpet and then in The Telecast they
were behind someone who was like hosting
or announcing something and you could
see them kissing in the background I
still don't think they're dating yeah I
didn't know who young gravy was until
last week because he was on Sofia with
an f and I watched a clip of what he was
talking about and he said that he was
talking about like having all these
girls in different like uh ports pretty
much and like pose in different area
codes yeah but they're like real like
relationships when he's with them but he
has like multiple of these people so I
just hope like Sherry's not getting too
invested because I now know that he has
a lot of other girlfriends who feel
really special and that she'll never
just be his one and only
um so I'm grateful to Sofia with an F
for doing um that investigative work for
us I don't think though that they're
actually dating but like
for to do that on the red carpet like
Where's Addison this is just like not a
great look no this is the takeaway for
me from the story Addison Ray's parents
are disgraceful after
first of all after Addison made it and
started growing and getting all these
opportunities for brand deals and acting
yada yada the way she brought her
parents along for the ride whether it
was what she wanted whether it was they
wanted was admirable you know like
nobody really gets famous and puts their
parents at the Forefront of
the the spotlight like it was it was
always a little weird honestly like the
way that her parents had Tick-Tock
accounts that were verified and would
make dancing videos like it's [ __ ]
weird first of all then not only that
but for them to then have this and by
the way things things happen people
break up to handle it in such a
disgusting way on both of their parts
honestly more so Monty the Cherry but
now both of them is so embarrassing for
Addison her parents are acting out of
control they're acting like the kids
especially her dad I'm sure Addison is
not talking to her dad and we know she's
not talking to her mom and honestly I
feel that yeah also it's like to the
whole world who's watching this like
Sherry's showing up with young gravy if
they just walk the carpet together and
we could have been like ooh titillating
but like them like making out PDI even
if they are dating like stop you know
yeah it the whole world is like watching
and like no one's thinking this is like
cool cute shipping so it's really just
to get back at Monty and it's like oh
okay so you care so you care about this
like disgusting piece of [ __ ] up until
this point Sherry was above ever
everything Monty was doing was so like
low brow so tacky and Sherry was
remaining above it even though there was
you know for me at least like questions
as to why her and Addison weren't
talking and why she followed her mom on
it unfollowed her mom on Instagram but
now Sherry's like playing dirty just
like Monty and they're both honestly
disgraceful yeah yeah like look at what
they're doing to their daughter who's
literally had this you know historic
unprecedented success on her way to
being you know a true fixture in
Hollywood as a celebrity whether it's
acting or doing beauty or just social
media like she's a very you know hopeful
career ahead of her and her parents
acting like this like bringing her down
to a level that's so tacky when like
she's out in Malibu with the Kardashians
like look how well she's done for
herself yeah and they both want to you
know chip away at that by being
two-year-olds yeah
I agree it's unacceptable and it's
really embarrassing I'm embarrassed for
them should be Addison on the red carpet
of course where is Dixie it's like Dixie
demilio walking Addison's mom and her 25
year old boyfriend walking like are
these people okay but also Where's
Addison like I know she's been on an
Italian vacation for a year but
where is she she probably took some time
off and then all this stuff happened and
she just extended that time off because
honestly she should not have to answer
or really be a part of this like if her
parents want to act wild then that's on
them and she really shouldn't have to
step out and do a red carpet and be
asked about that it's not her [ __ ]
problem and she can't
really control how her parents are
acting so you know what I would take a
break too like relax yeah as far as
other things that happened at the VMAs
um Nicki Minaj like won a Lifetime
Achievement Award so happy for her uh
her new song is really good I'm not
gonna lie I have been very critical of
Nikki especially because I didn't think
it was cool the way she you know was the
only female rapper for a really long
time and then when it came time for
cardi B like she was not gracious let's
she was not
um
and then obviously you know there's a
lot in her personal life that is unique
um but then she did the Potomac reunion
and she crawled her way back a little
bit but then and then I started to like
like her on a personal level but I
really thought like she would not come
back as like the queen of rap I thought
that time was kind of over for her
um but she just really super freak and
it's a [ __ ] Bop one thing about me
I'm the baddest still alive
um and like I only know it because of
Tick Tock but now I like want to listen
to it on Spotify like her rap is just so
good like it's so on point like every
word makes perfect [ __ ] sense you
know yeah it's so on point one thing
about me I'm the bad is still that
it's fictitious like she used the word
fictitious like perfect I say t word I
don't know the song yet but I've gotta
add to my Spotify it's really good
cool well anything else that happened uh
I didn't watch by the way I didn't watch
some of the red carpet looks were here
or there unique I thought Sabrina
Carpenter looked unreal I completely
agree I thought lizza looked a little
silly I'm sorry I love her dearly yeah
um but that dress was just a no for me
but you know what that's fashion it's
everyone's Choice
um Jeff Cameron looked a little a little
bad
um
Dixie demilio looked Gore yeah she's a
class act that girl yeah
good stuff good stuff yeah
and it was in New Jersey right are you
ready for our next story I am Olivia
Wilde asked Shia LaBeouf not to quit the
movie don't worry darling in a leaked
video saying quote I'm not ready to give
up this is really like really bad yes so
a previously reported video message that
Olivia Wilde sent Shia LaBeouf asking
him to reconsider his decision to leave
don't worry darling has leaked the full
contents of the video were reported by
variety but the video itself emerged
several hours later Shia had sent
variety the video in an effort to rebuff
Olivia Wilde's claims in a recent cover
story that she fired the actor from the
film due to disagreements over his
acting process Shia countered saying he
left the film on his own because he
couldn't find enough time to rehearse
with his co-stars Olivia Wilde
reportedly sent shy of the video several
days after he left don't worry darling
in August 2020 in the clip she says
quote I feel like I'm not ready to give
up on this yet and I'm too heartbroken
and want to figure this out
she also appears to allude to some
potential tension between Shia and
co-star Florence Pew saying quote I
think this might be a bit of a wake-up
call for Miss flow if she really commits
if she really puts her mind and heart
into it at this point and if you guys
can make peace and I respect your point
of view I respect hers but if you guys
can do it what do you think is their
hope a rep for Olivia did not return a
request for comment okay like not Olivia
Wilde being like the most fraudulent
feminist of all time like yeah like
talking to variety they and I I've seen
a lot of clips from this interview
variety did a big thing with her because
she's really kind of the next big female
director like if she's not already you
know she's getting to that level like
kind of how I feel about Mindy Kaling
like when she's associated with
something you know it's gonna have that
Olivia Wilde Vibe um so they did this
big article woman director yada yada
empowering women oh yeah I fired chai as
we all know Shia has been accused and is
currently being sued by some of his
ex-girlfriends for abhorrent abuse like
he's not a good guy in this scenario
though I do love
um how Petty he was like sending the
full video
so she's out here being a hero you know
I protect women yada yada I fired Chaya
I was tough with what we had to do and
then this video comes to light
um that not only proves that she was
lying but is actually incredibly cringy
for you know someone who wears a t-shirt
that says feminist AF you know yeah
yeah she not only is asking Shia not to
quit but to stay but it's also being
incredibly condescending to Florence
Pugh Miss flow like in the video her
tone is like obviously distasteful
towards Florence
um and wanting to side with Shia and
maybe that's not how she feels maybe she
thought that's how she would get shya to
agree all in all it's a really bad look
for Olivia Wilde especially and it's
made worse by the fact that like she is
obviously dating Harry Styles who has
these hordes of fans who do not like her
so the video is getting perpetuated even
more
um more than it would if she was just a
regular girl dating Jason Sudeikis you
know yes but I'm not even investing on
the Harry Styles piece but like this is
[ __ ] crazy just to be so caught
embarrassing I like that and to lie to
really prop yourself up to like and also
you know I'm very glad that he sent this
video forward because
and it's just like people just [ __ ]
lie and I know
when someone says when there's rumors or
this or that or sources like I can
always
give it the benefit of the doubt and be
like that's probably not true or like
maybe that didn't happen and so on but
this is full proof this is she said one
thing and the video shows that she
[ __ ] lied yeah no it's really bad
especially now you know
she's like that classic you know
celebrity who you know she went on Watch
What Happens Live her skirt was
embroidered feminist feminist feminist
feminist she wears t-shirts
informative [ __ ]
activism her feminist card is is being
rescinded for sure but also just like
your truthful human being card your
credibility your credibility
no it's really bad one because the video
is so obviously just like said one thing
but you did another
but also like this tension that has been
rumored up until this point with
Florence Pew is kind of like fully
validated now like it was really rude
Vibes in the video about Florence it's
been reported that Florence is not going
to do any press for this movie except
for the Venice Film Festival that's the
one thing she's gonna do and honestly
I'm with her like first of all your
director who's a woman so you're like
finally I'm getting a woman director she
can finally understand what it's like to
be a woman in this business someone I
can lean on perhaps be a mentor to me
and she's [ __ ] you know being sneaky
behind your back trying to get your
co-star who's just been exposed for
being like a violent abuser she's trying
to get him back on then she ends up
dating the lead they keep running away
together no one's on set no one's
working no one's being professional I'm
sure she's like [ __ ] this forlorn
project I wish I never signed on you
know what I owe Florence and apology I
was wrong because I you were doubtful
you weren't wrong I said like she's
probably bitter about the movie because
like if anyone was in me dating Harry
Styles on set it was going to be her and
then so not what her issue is here and
it's more layered I was wrong and I
apologize because it's so much more
layered and yet this sounds like a
miserable work experience a toxic work
and atmosphere yeah but like just even
the shy apart and I guess like what
she's saying is she's trying to get Miss
flow to rehearse more with him kind of
like what he wanted like because he's
very methody and like wants everyone
rehearsing all the time and I guess low
probably didn't want to be around it was
probably like this is a nine to five I'm
going home like we'll pick up tomorrow
and we're gonna meet in the middle of
like spending more time that's what I'm
getting that's putting the pieces
together that's probably where the
biggest disconnect was so it's like Not
only was she gonna like
try and make Florence like method act
like Shia who also is like
a alleged abuser problematic guy you
want to be spending extra time with
right alone time then they finally
figure out that piece and with Shia who
left he wasn't even Olivia making the
right decision for Florence it was shy
which is so embarrassing and then okay
so we bring on Harry Styles and now it's
like you're running off with him
Florence is directing this you know I
apologize I was so wrong that's very big
of you
um I like before this whole Saga I know
like the Teeny bot like gen Z is
obsessed with Florence peo and to be
honest like I was not familiar at all
mostly because I haven't seen um Little
Women and that's where like she has like
a cult following from so I didn't really
know anything about her and I was just
very kind of you know neutral about her
now I feel as though I like her a lot
like knowing what she's been through and
still acting with such grace even though
I am such grace even though I'm sure
she's so happy this is that this video
was was sent in because one it shows
that Olivia Wilde is a liar Tim it shows
the toxic ass environment that she
worked from and now people probably
understand why she doesn't want to
promote this film like she wants to be
done with it and she comes out the hero
so my only question is like what does
Olivia Wilde do now like this is so bad
and so embarrassing for her and she was
like ascending this very small you know
to this very small group of female
directors you know and now it's like
ew I'm sure she'll be fine I'm sure like
she'll just keep doing whatever she was
doing but I think for the fans
especially people who like didn't know
where to fall on on this particular
movie issue and people really love
Florence and people really love Olivia
Wilde like it's
I wonder if Florence even knew about
this video I wonder for sure not for
sure not I'm sure she probably knew that
Olivia Wilde did not fire Shia LaBeouf
she probably knew that
yeah she knew that Shia quit and then
she sees Olivia running around town
being you know a hero for women when she
didn't even have the balls to fire the
alleged abuser in the movie he had to
quit yeah like it's so embarrassing I'm
like I'm embarrassed yeah it's really
embarrassing
yikes Olivia that's really it can it's
giving yikes
it's yikes worthy yeah
so let's see what happens next but all
of this to say I gotta see this movie
right so I'm you know no press is is bad
press so I'm curious if this is helping
the film
um I saw like a little teaser they
released
I don't know if I need to see it I don't
know that I will see it but even though
there are some sexy Harry Styles moments
this does make me more interested in
seeing it I don't know if it's enough to
see it but I didn't care one iota before
any of this happened yeah I would have
also assumed the movie already came out
you know felt like forever since right
when they met on set like right yada
yada so true
are you ready for our next story
is it the next story that's brought to
you by uh away yes because someone's
packing their bags I am and I only use
away suitcases they make suitcases bags
and other travel accessories that are
designed to make moving through the
world a lot more seamless which is a
good thing because travel makes us
better people giving us different
perspectives so matter no matter where
you're going you can always rely on a
Waze range of travel products to solve
real-time travel problems and get you
out there so they have a range of
suitcases bags and other travel
Essentials that are all made of
different materials and they also come
in a variety of colors and sizes so if
you're in the market for a new suitcase
I cannot recommend a way enough I've had
one of my carry-on sizes for years it's
in great shape
um I have the big one I have three
little carry-on sizes in pink in Black
the colors are really cute they're built
to last they have four 360 degree Wheels
I cannot deal with pushing my air my uh
suitcase through an airport especially
when it's carpeted it is the worst thing
on the planet the away suitcases are
really seamless to roll they come with a
laundry bag inside they come with this
little sponge item that you can use to
scuff out any buff marks on the outside
if you know bag baggage handlers are
getting a little rough you use your
little sponge buff it out good to do
we've all seen the videos of the baggage
schindlers right exactly they also offer
free shipping and Returns on any
non-personalized order within U.S Canada
and UK they also come with the TSA
approved combination lock to keep all of
your belongings safe there's also a
100-day trial on uh everything that away
makes so you can take the product on the
road if you decide that it's not for you
you can return any non-personalized item
in under 100 days you'll get a full
refund no ifs ands or Bots start your
100 day trial and Shop the entire away
lineup of travel Essentials including
their best-selling suitcases and bags at
awaytravel.com toast that's
awaytravel.com toast
thank you our next story shocking news
this morning Kelsey ballerini files for
divorce from Morgan Evans it's over for
Kelsey ballerini and Morgan Evans the
singer filed for divorce from the
musician on Friday after nearly five
years of marriage people confirms a
source tells people that quote they've
been working on their marriage for a
very long time prior to this they had
separated privately once before and have
been in therapy for several years they
gave it their best go but I'm
unfortunately arrived at the decision to
formally separate
she addressed the split on her Instagram
story this morning saying friends I've
always tried my best to share my life
with you in a real and vulnerable way
while also protecting layers of my
personal life as they unfold this is now
public record so I wanted you to hear
from me directly that I'm going through
a divorce this deeply difficult decision
is a result of a journey of Love growth
and effort that ultimately has come to
an end it's hard to find the words here
but I feel extremely grateful for the
years of marriage to Morgan and hopeful
and hopeful for the next seasons with
very active schedules coming up please
be mindful that we are both fragile
actively healing and showing up the best
that we can
okay let me say one thing when all these
women in country like these young women
in country were getting married it was
all around the same time Kelsey
ballerini and Morgan Evans
Casey Musgraves and that guy's name who
died I don't remember and Ryan Hurd and
Marin Morris like all three of these
like huge women in country were getting
married like around the same time all to
men like significantly less successful
than them
in the same industry yeah which I
thought was like really interesting of
course we all know Casey musgrave's
marriage was the first to bite the
bullet now K uh Kelsea ballerini and I
do feel as though Marin Morris's
marriage is like really strong yeah um
and I don't think that they're headed
the way the other two are headed but
it's just interesting to know now like
four or five years later that two out of
three of those marriages did not last
yeah and we'll never know what the
issues were um but I imagine from an
outside glance it's very hard to one be
in the same industry as someone and to
be married and in the exact same space
and it's like just so obvious when one
person is more successful than the other
like I feel like a lot of other people
who are you know maybe I'm a singer in
this genre you're a singer in that genre
or I'm an actor you're a singer Nicole
Kidman
jealousy because there's no crossover
but to be in the exact same category and
fighting for the same you know
opportunity recognition minutes on the
radio Etc and like one person is having
so much success like
it takes a really
I don't even want to say a big person
but like it's just a a certain type of
person to not have any issues with that
right because like jealousy and
competition like those are natural human
emotions especially if you're like a a
hustler like you are motivated to be
successful so I can't imagine that's the
entire reason why
um but I think it leads to other
problems in the marriage because if
you're not entirely happy with where
you're at in life you know you take that
out on the people around you and again
this is all just
guessing but I just can't imagine it
doesn't have at least something to do
with it because when you think about
where they started and now where they
are like Kelsey is bigger than ever you
know her next album's coming out the
three songs she released are so [ __ ]
good like she can like she's just
killing it she performs everywhere she
does festivals she headlines and Morgan
who released his first album A couple of
years ago that I thought was incredible
like really filled with the most
beautiful music I like haven't heard
from him since yeah he's definitely more
low-key but he's unbelievably talented
right we love his music Rustin Kelly
that was his name oh yes yeah
um
it's just it I'm sure it throws a wrench
into what is already difficult
institution of marriage
but I I don't know if this is like you
know too soon to say I am excited that
eventually Kelsea ballerini will be
dating because she's kind of like this
Bell of the ball in country music I
don't know if she's going to continue to
date within country music but she's like
this beautiful young girl and I just
think like who she dates next will be
really fun for us to watch and also
really good for her career for sure but
I do feel like he'll be in a
relationship first that's how it always
goes yeah but like I don't think you
know people care
10-2
yeah I'm just I'm I'm excited for her to
heal and then be spotted out with I
don't know Brad Pitt like yeah oh I'll
add her to the list but oh yeah I'll
have to put her under a category of not
healed yet not here yeah TBD
oh and you know who I'm taking off the
list I was singing the same thing get
rid of her she doesn't deserve it uh
until she starts to act like a grown-up
then perhaps we'll consider putting her
back on but until then no no no okay
Kelsey ballerini and Chris Evans
cute Kelsey ballerini and Michael B
Jordan
cute
Kelsey ballerini and Josh Groban
obsessed
even though I feel like he's a lot older
than her
he seems you know mature yeah for sure
because she's been in this industry you
know for a long time she said to grow up
quickly yeah exactly I'm also really
excited for her album like she's been
killing it with the singles that have
come out love is a cowboy I haven't
listened to new music because I listened
to the same five songs over and over
again just like as a mom I feel that and
the rotation changes constantly but
these days it's middle of somewhere by
Luke Combs just want to say we've never
like fully debriefed the album but um I
think it's it's so hard because this
one's for you is also an incredible
album but like this album growing up is
[ __ ]
10 out of 10. like there's only one
thing that's bad about it and that's
that it's not [ __ ] long enough every
time I get to the end I'm like wait what
the Music Stops I'm like what also
outrunning your memory we love that song
we sing with Miranda and I think part of
the reason why I feel like the album's
not long enough is because I think one
of my perhaps my favorite song is the
last one that girl is going going on so
good you'd Love This Bar
I stumbled on
it's so good like if you like country
music if you don't like country music
it's a and the songs are like they're
kind of like emotional like he's tapping
into things that like you know you think
in your head but you don't say like I'm
so glad you know
uh I'm glad I'm not anybody else because
I used to wish I was like things like
that that like we all feel but would
never even admit like yeah I used to
hate myself like it's so real and it's
not like and it has the country you know
whiskey me or may or never broke like it
has that but it also has a depth to it
that's like kind of like emo he's just
sharing Universal truths yes no matter
where you're from
what your genre is it's Universal truths
it's literally it's a work of art it's a
work of art middle of summer is my
favorite song and now running your
memory and then the other five in the
rotation that we're always listening to
is now obviously can't help falling in
love and if I Can Dream by Elvis is my
new favorite song I never knew it before
I listened to it probably 20 times a day
all different versions of it
it's so good better back when for Luke
Combs is is up there for me
as is going going gone and used to wish
I was
oh but I'm glad I'm not I'm just in Old
Carolina girl
are you ready for our fifth and final
story
oh my God already yeah
it's some TV News Daily pop and nightly
pop have been canceled at eam e is
canceling two of its daily entertainment
news shows the daily the daytime talk
show Daily pop will and its five year
run in September and companion nightly
pop will go dark in October the NBC
Universal owned cable outlet also plans
to launch a new evening show in October
that will return to the roots of the E
news brand as the gold standard of
entertainment news coverage according to
a memo from Tracy Wilson executive VP
syndication Studios at NBC Universal to
e-staff on Friday she wrote I know
change can be challenging but I'm truly
excited about the future of these brands
that we are going to build together the
whole email is like all over the
internet but the headline is that daily
pop and nightly pop are
dunzo e
is so moronic and they have not been
okay for years
I don't know like who who on the planet
decided to cancel e-news like they
should be fired immediately that was
just a terrible idea because that was
really what he was known for and maybe
it needed to be improved and fixed in
some different ways but that's what
they've claimed to be was like this pop
culture Network and E news was honestly
the only brand in their catalog that had
recognized like we all know E news
everybody wanted to be on E news growing
up like they could have evolved if there
was problems but like whoever canceled
he knews like a terrible idea then they
had this whole slate of morning
programming pop of the morning daily pop
nightly pop they pop of the morning was
literally forlorn it was the dumbest
thing I've ever heard and I love him but
like why the [ __ ] was Victor Cruz the
host he's a former football player like
what the [ __ ] does he know about the
Kardashians like it made no sense and
they never really ever lean into digital
culture you know they have the rundown
which is like their SnapChat thing and
they're always bringing on like
podcasters and tick-tockers to do it but
like they need to bring that energy to
cable because nobody is really caring
about most of the talent that they
procure but having said that in the last
couple of years they've done a good job
of finding good talent Justin Morgan
Nina Hunter and so not only have they
canceled their shows but like they
really never like nurtured that they
really should have like been putting
more energy more resources towards those
four people because they were coming
like becoming like the new faces like a
younger generation of e and they just
canceled it so like what are they doing
and what original shows do they even
have anymore and why the Bradshaw Bunch
that's it yeah it must be doing so well
like I I don't know I love telepop I
can't believe it's ending I know I don't
know what their new strategy is maybe
they're gonna focus more on nighttime
sure but like then why not nightly pop
also E's whole thing is you know pop of
culture so we were getting pop in the
morning and pop in the evenings like are
they also going to do a whole nother
Rebrand we all just got used to
like yeah it's so silly every few years
there's like a re-org and but we're all
like when there's an internal reorg
we're not supposed to really feel it or
know about it but it's like every single
few years they're taking us along this
with them I can't imagine what it's like
to be working there to be one of the
hosts did everyone know that this was
coming did people find out in the news
I don't know and what does this mean for
some of our faves like Morgan still does
necessary realness so is she still
technically with e what does this mean
for Justin I mean Justin has been doing
you know like almost now like maybe
monthly or weekly spots on The Today
Show he's amazing he's so funny I hope
if there's a job there for him they give
it to him because like honestly e has
all these talented people and their
talents are going to waste he does not
appreciate them e is moronic they are
not in tune with what's necessary and
it's so shocking to me that like out of
all this crap they've been throwing at
the wall these last few years they
actually got two really substantial
shows that were good that had a good
following and
they're just canceling it after they've
made all this progress like I literally
don't understand yeah I mean who I don't
know what the ratings were but maybe
there was like a dip because I don't
think you would cancel like the most
right watch show but like can I tell you
so we
we reformulate
if there was a dip in ratings and I
don't think either of the shows had like
the highest of ratings and I want to
tell you that has nothing to do with the
format of the show or the host it has
everything to do with e now having this
horrendous reputation of being like the
messy Network like honestly they're
giving Demi Lovato every few years like
no this is the real us we're gonna be
this yeah I agree it's like well what
are you also I feel like now with
especially without E news and now
especially without daily pop and nightly
pop like they're just like an Instagram
rom-com no they're an Instagram account
with the posts like right they're an
influencer
yeah
yeah
like every
channel has a brand you know and you
know what you're gonna get on that like
on Bravo you know you're gonna get
reality shows mostly centered in big
cities around different subcultures you
know what you're gonna get you turn on
sci-fi you know what you're gonna get
you turn on uh
VH1 you know what you're gonna get now
it's like you turn on E and you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on like it's a
zoom show with Kevin Hart in people's
closets right or it's a Sweet Home
Alabama like what what is your Vibe I
know well there's so messy what they'll
say now is like they're gonna figure it
out and they're gonna reorganize but
it's but I thought they had figured it
out five years ago with their new
morning slate live from New York and
then live from and they were doing like
all female content like every single
show on there right network was female
focused it was like very Cavalieri total
Bellas Total Divas it was all females
that was pretty good lady gang but yeah
I did that didn't work I firmly believe
like lady gang was not given a good
enough long enough shot because I think
that show had legs
yeah so I don't know
yeah and I just thought I was like okay
give them a minute you're taking for the
first time ever podcast and making it
into a television show it takes time for
people to adjust like it's not maybe the
first season is not gonna break the
records the Clarita is the Phillips
they've just been dropping the ball for
years mclartia
yeah Busy Phillips
and it's just sad that the network that
I think like as Millennial women used to
grow up and everyone's dream job was to
like be on E news be the next Juliana
the dream is dead yeah you couldn't pay
me and you know what I'm actually really
happy in a sense if this canceling of
the show gives Justin and Morgan like
more freedom because I do think those
jobs like they keep you really busy
they're really restrictive in terms of
what else you can do your contract is
really tight I don't think you can be
out here you know doing different
Partnerships and doing podcasts and the
two of them they're both so talented and
so funny and people really love them so
I hope that like in a way the show
getting canceled releases them from
their shackles like yeah go do a podcast
do a web show like you're hilarious yeah
I wonder if they're still with e though
I don't know necessary realness I know
Justin has like a
you know what they should really do
like a like a Kelly and Ryan of e with
Justin and Morgan That's daily pop
yeah I guess that what and Morgan
doesn't want to do that right right
because she has kids like why don't they
make it like a three o'clock show
I mean they obviously know a lot a
little bit more than us like about
viewer how what time of the day yeah
so I guess I'll be doing this nightly
show they're gonna put everything into
like a big nightly program and I I would
hope that they're using the talent that
they have the talent that people like
and want to see but I hope then why not
just revamp nightly pop and make it you
know an hour and a different setup
different format
now this is like he isn't is
embarrassing this is the episode of
embarrassment everyone's out here
embarrassing themselves yeah the
E stands for embarrassing
embarrassing entertainment
I love that
um well those are the Fast Five and boy
were they juicy I mean what a weekend
what a weekend and we'll have more for
you tomorrow it's not it's far from over
would we like to do Game of Thrones
series Game of Thrones so episode two of
the House of the Dragon was last night
it was one of those episodes you know
when you get you know if you're familiar
with Game of Thrones you know that
there's two types of episodes one is you
know where lots of explosive things
happen plot twists huge moments and the
others are episodes that set the the
groundwork they really settle you know
move things around so that those big
explosive moments can happen yeah and
last night was very much you know like a
setting a setting of the scenes it
wasn't that explosive but you know like
things that happen in this episode maybe
in episode five like something [ __ ]
crazy will happen and it'll be because
you know we staged it in in episode two
so it wasn't crazy but I think obviously
the big takeaways were one that the King
has decided to marry that brunette
girlie as opposed to the child
which on one hand I was relieved he
wasn't marrying Lena the 12 year old
because it was disgusting
and on the other hand I'm upset you know
for raniera her bestie it was a betrayal
now her stepmother and you know
she was making such good progress with
her dad I do feel like if she ends up
having you know some sort of break with
her dad like it will be detrimental for
the realm and he's trying and she's
trying but he lied to her and he
betrayed her and he didn't even have the
decency to tell her when they were
having the conversation about remarriage
that he was thinking about marrying her
brunette bestie so I do feel like this
is a huge huge betrayal for her and is
perhaps going to lead to Damon's cutting
off cutting off her dad which is not
going to be good no it will lead her
right into Damon's arms I do wonder if
like there and the game I don't know you
also have to like just suspend some of
the things that you think are Uncle
Weird Uncle little Uncle loving and the
12. by the way I mean we should have
married they're not the same Jackie I
can separate uncle
and not Uncle like I can separate and
ship so you're okay with incest but
you're not okay with like uh blurry
pedophilia yeah am I crazy that
pedophilia is worse than anything so he
wouldn't bet her till she was 14.
oh how gracious of him I was not into
that I got why it made sense the merging
of powerful homes Valeria and Targaryen
and when they cut to when they were
saying they have a kid I'm like oh no
rage probably young so cute I thought
that Lena was in the first episode she
was but I'm like oh they must have
another daughter no and I don't remember
her being so young I thought she was
like we're near his age just a little
long but not she was 12. I thought she
was like 15. when they were like we have
a daughter I'm like Oh we must have not
have met that one yet because it can't
be the toddler from the tourney
and I'm like this is disgusting so on
one hand I'm like sad that raniera has
been betrayed but on the other hand I'm
grateful that that young lady Lena has
been saved from a lifetime of misery
with this old ugly King yeah who's not
doing well about to lose a digit uh oh
the digit with the maggots that was
really disgusting okay but also time is
moving so quickly quicker than the mom
died six months ago okay mom died six
months ago did you watch a preview for
next week
no actually baby is born
and he has a full head of blonde
Targaryen hair whoo wait who is a baby
Allison
please stop spoiling is that a spoiler
in the preview no it is I didn't want to
know in the previews for next week I
don't want her as a toddler
damn well I love when well I love when
things move fast because
one more happens and two like in these
old-timey worlds like it would take a
month for them to go to Dragonstone so
I'm grateful I didn't have to wait like
next year's episode is like three years
later
damn that's actually a long time but you
know what maybe it's like now it's
really a Game of Thrones because
Allison's son
right now he exists he exists and he
would he usurps rhaenyra
that will force rhaenyra to do something
to Damon's arms no are you shipping now
I'm obsessed I am kind of shipping and
so maybe these first two episodes were
kind of like the prequel to Now The
Story begins that's a good call by the
way maybe
and this episode I was like actually
really vibing with the King like he
thought it was weird about the 12 year
old he understood why he was good but he
also thought it was weird
um he wanted to prioritize his
relationship with his daughter he
apologized for not being so
communicative after his mom died he
apologized that as a part of his job he
has to remarry like I was really on his
side until he ended up handling it so
poorly okay like yes I agree and I think
the king is is a good guy but he's not a
great king because he's not like strong
in his convictions and he doesn't have
that many convictions but there's
something about this like episode of
Game of Thrones where it's like we're
watching like a father trying to bond
with his teenage daughter like a king
try like who cares it feels like we're
watching you know a rom-com from 2022 of
like you know a single father trying to
bond his daughter you know what if
you're right about these two episodes
kind of like being the prequel then that
actually makes sense because we need to
understand how and why renera would then
betray her father and turn to Damon okay
fine but it was giving like they don't
talk about their feelings in the
Medieval ages yeah even though I did
like love that the dad was like very you
know communicative and no but it's just
interested because everyone in the
medieval times was like so evil it was
so 20 22 like tell me about your
feelings
yeah the dad is weak like he's not the
he's nothing of the sort yeah somebody
lied to him several times and told him
he was a good kid at least he said he's
nothing like that okay nothing of the
sword in Game of Thrones like you could
get at Joffrey you could get a Ramsay oh
you know who I wanted to [ __ ] slap
the woman the queen that never was shut
up wench I have two things to say I
think that there's two really bad
actresses in the show who are kind of
bringing it down I think she's a bad
actress I agree and I think the [ __ ] is
a bad actress oh Jackie that was my next
Point first of all she was being such a
bad actress when they went back inside
after this explaining and complaining
she doesn't want to be his wife yeah and
it was like I was running away and he
was like from what and in the worst
acting I've ever seen fear what I agree
and that's something that Game of
Thrones has always consistently been
above I cannot tell you an actor who was
miscast or who did a bad job on game of
of Thrones I cannot the [ __ ] has to go
in the Game of Thrones of yore we would
never be hearing like the horse
the horse feels
right the horse feelings are irrelevant
a grade
and Damon who's like very volatile yeah
he's sitting there listening that would
never happen it's just like a little so
unrealistic and it's too many feelings
like Game of Thrones is you know
you live or you die you don't feel
no like in the Regular Show if the
horror went on and on about her feelings
she'd be put to death head on the spike
yeah like stop talking wench
so I thought that was weird too
um and when raniera came in on the
dragon I was like Queen being Queen
she's giving Danny Targaryen She's
Everything of the sort Damon loves her
because he finally gave her back the egg
I ship romance at its finest yeah yeah
but the queen that never was his husband
is really pissing me off even though
he's right like no and you can't sit
idly by while the free cities you can't
but my God like chill out and it's also
like
he's in a very high position of power
everyone around the table is like
jockeying to be on the iron throne but
it's like is anyone just [ __ ] happy
with their station it's like okay I
don't want the pressure of being King
I've got a great life I've got my own
castle I'm not gonna make every move in
my life trying to get me or a family
member on the third yeah no nobody feels
that way and it's not fair because
nobody really cares about the free City
thing because it doesn't affect them yet
but it really affects him because he's
like you know the house of the sales the
Sailor the sailors the the sea
um so it's gonna affect him first but
then it's going to affect the realm in
the wall that's like jumping on the wall
right exactly so it's not fair and of
course I knew he was going to go to
Damon like maybe Damon will do something
about it but then I did love how he was
like don't talk [ __ ] about my family
only I'm allowed to talk [ __ ] about
myself we're right about Damon I need to
go when we watch the first episode and
like oh my God not me being right about
something period and especially about
Game of Thrones because like I'm so dumb
people be like you didn't see that
coming I was like I had no idea I
thought that in the first episode like
the small Council was just a bunch of
like weak losers but not nefarious
actors
Otto Hightower like is Littlefinger
Ben said the exact same thing who was
that chubby man that he that the king
went to for his on
he sits on the Bible Council I don't
know who he is exactly okay but he's a
he's a good guy one of the good ones
um so all in all it was like a fine
episode nothing crazy happened but not
every episode can be crazy obviously and
we need to we needed to set the scene
for next week so
it was good we're setting the scene in
the middle of the episode Zach was like
this [ __ ] sucks I was like we remember
how slow it was nobody remembers how
slow season one was because nobody
watched season one week to week but
imagine watching that we tweak you have
never stuck with it no and I still
thought it was good it's better than
most shows so I'm better than most shows
but it's a little it's a lot of feelings
for Westeros because we're only focused
on one family it's a lot of the same
people whereas like even a boring
episode of Game of Thrones get
Winterfell you would get the wall you
would get King's Landing you would get
Arya you would get a lot of different
updates from different people and on
this show it's one family so it's just a
lot of the same people that's why it
might feel in the red keep the whole
time right true that
so I loved it I love the Recaps they're
so much fun with you [ __ ] poo
and I think it's time to unburden
ourselves let's do it I can't wait for
you guys to emburn yourselves uh every
Monday we are doing unburden yourselves
which is a segment where you guys can
write in about something you went
through this week that is weighing so
heavily on you that the only way to get
rid of the burden is to hand it over to
us you can email us unburdenyourselves
gmail.com and it is brought to you by
modern fertility we're supposed to go to
the ob gyn once a year for our annual
checkups but checking in with our
fertility isn't usually a thing until
we're ready for kids but that's why
modern fertility was created an easy and
affordable way to test your fertility
hormones at home with a simple finger
prick mail it in with a prepaid label
and you'll get personalized results
within 10 days you'll get insights into
your hormone levels your ovarian reserve
and other important fertility factors
the results go deep into what every
hormone means and you can download the
results to review with your doctor for
next steps traditional testing can cost
over a thousand dollars at the doctor
but modern fertility gets you the same
information at a fraction of the price
if you go to modernfertility.com toast
you'll also get 20 off your test so
modern fertility is offering our
listeners 20 off the test at
modernfertility.com toast which means
that your test will cost 179 instead of
the hundreds of thousands hundreds or
thousands it could cost to the doctor
get twenty percent twenty dollars off
your fertility test when you go to
modernfertility.com toast that's 179
dollars to 20 off modernfertility.com
toast all right ready to one bird and
yourselves
hello Jackson Claude I've been keeping
this in and I need to unburden myself
during quarantine I was living with my
parents and I stumbled upon something
interesting I was home alone and I
wanted to do some karaoke
I wrote this in
my mom's laptop was downstairs and mine
was upstairs so I just used hers for
YouTube because I'm lazy
and she doesn't mind if I use it I went
into her history for some reason and saw
multiple fully watched gay porn videos
although there's nothing wrong with that
of course my mom is very religious who
has she has very traditional views and
this was the last thing I expected also
who uses YouTube for porn I mean I know
she was probably curious but I couldn't
look at her the same way for days I got
over it but it still lurks in my mind
every now and then
he just got it on that burden and forget
about it
yeah I think you truly never know
someone even if it's your own mother you
know that's the takeaway here yeah and
it wasn't meant for you to know so you
just need to unknow it now
right and you don't know what the
context of like why she was searching
for it is you know
maybe she met someone who was like I'm a
gay porn actor so she was like wanting
to see his work you never know like
things happen it's not probably she was
watching gay porn but right let's be
real but it could have been other stuff
too
um and you just have to forget about it
yeah and I think obviously you shouldn't
be thinking about the fact that your mom
watches gay porn but if anything perhaps
you might have a little you know respect
for it like well she's more open-minded
than I thought I underestimated my mom I
thought she was this religious
traditional closed-minded person but
she's actually you know a lover of gay
porn a curious Queen
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it but again it's obviously awkward
yeah
um just try not to think about it just
try not to think about it and just know
like even moms have secrets
yeah yeah hey Jackson Claude I love you
both and I really need to unburden
myself
two weeks ago my co-worker and I had to
glue together 200 invites For an
upcoming work event while gluing the
cards I drew a dick on the invite
thinking that the glue would just dry
clear my co-worker and I both laughed
and thought it was okay to send well my
boss just sent us a text with a picture
of the invite and the dick that was
clearly still on it the glue did not dry
clear it's just me and my co-worker that
glued these invitations so I must own up
to my cute little drawing and tell my
boss that it was me I am so embarrassed
I don't even know how to respond to him
love a girl who might be jobless oh
just so no to it you know things happen
and the fact that like your boss is a
male like just makes it like a little
more like I think a girly might be able
to laugh at it
but this is like makes it weird yeah
this is just awkward it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate but just zoom out you
know zoom out and be grateful that he
sent you the invitation while it was
still on his desk not when you know the
CEO received it right exactly it always
can be worse and it's just a silly
little thing just be really apologetic
be like oh my God I totally thought it
would dry clear I would this is so
unprofessional I would never do it again
I'm really sorry like It's always
important when you're getting in trouble
before you actually get yelled at to
totally acknowledge that you're wrong
apologize admit why it was wrong and say
it'll never happen again because then
the person who's about to yell at you
like they don't really have their names
you've already said it you've said
everything that needs to be said you
neutralize the threat
and this is just a lesson obviously um
you never know what glue is going to
look like and perhaps leave drawings of
dicks to your personal items that's it
into your personal life you know
personal affairs if you're in the
workplace like no situation unless
you're working in gay porn like should
you be driving
or you work at like a dildo factory and
you need to schedule you're coming up
with designs a new prototype yeah you
could say to your boss like I have a
part-time job at the field toe Factory
and I just got my papers mixed I just
got confused I'm so sorry right right
yeah this this is bad but if you just
own up to it I don't think it's a
fireball offense hopefully your boss is
like young and funny and cool if he's
like old and stuffy I mean that's gonna
be awkward but he sounds like if he
texted it to you that means he's young
because older people don't know how to
send text let alone photos yeah so he's
it sounds like he's young and obviously
he went to college everyone used to draw
dicks everywhere it's fine
it's fine all right are you ready for
our third and final ready
hello Jax Claude rosenstrasse I have
been holding on to this for two months
and I cannot seem to get the awful
cringe out of my head I'll keep it short
and not so sweet earlier this summer my
parents were throwing a party and needed
to borrow some of my patio furniture so
their guests had places to sit no
problem at all I got up early knowing my
dad would be over to grab the chairs and
the table I worked out I took a full
shower you know shaved everything deep
conditioning one of those Flash Forward
my dad stops by he's loading up the
furniture and he asked to use my
bathroom before he heads back home I
obviously had told him to go right ahead
I sat on the couch to watch tick tocks
or something about an hour later I had
to pee so I walked into my bathroom to
find that I had left the shower curtain
open and the floor of my bathroom is of
the floor of my bathtub is covered in
tiny little hairs not only for my legs
but my pubes were just sitting there
staring back at me the drain must have
backed up I was mortified I stood in
shock until I mustered up the courage to
text my mom and ask if dad mentioned
anything about my bathroom thankfully he
didn't say anything to her but I can't
stop thinking about the fact that my dad
probably thinks I shaved a ginormous
bush in time for their summer bash thank
a clean but regretful toaster oh it's
okay it's just your dad and like he
doesn't know what hair is what yeah I
don't think like a grown dad would look
at a bathtub full of shower and think
pubes Men first of all are not even that
perceptive perceptive he probably didn't
even look in the tub like he wasn't even
and if he did see it he would think oh
maybe you know your husband shaved his
beard when men see hairs like that they
think how it happens for them when they
shave their beard in the sink you know
they get their hairs everywhere yeah I
think it's just a human thing and it
could have been so many hairs could have
been armpit hair could have been like
hair could you could have given yourself
a little trim of your right head hair
hey just keep that in your head as like
if you ever if it ever comes up be like
Dad I cut my hair yeah men don't see
hair at the bottom of the tub and think
pubes I really don't think that they
know also it's like okay so if he knew
that it was your pubes like okay
no if he knew it was your poops like I
understand no it's like even yourself
yes it's it's embarrassing but it's like
not a big deal like no one got hurt
everything's okay
yeah well you know that actually had me
thinking something I was thinking while
getting ready this morning
um that I wanted to just like hopefully
bring up in conversation and now it
actually does because you know I get all
the time people are always like oh my
God I'm so jealous of your hair it's so
thick it's so healthy it's so shiny and
it is it is all of those things but the
next time you're feeling bad about not
having like thick healthy hair just know
that like the hair on my head and like
that energy that the hair brings like
brings itself in my armpits and my legs
too you know yeah so if you have Fair
hair just know like you don't have some
of the problems I have okay I just I
don't know why I was thinking about that
but I was like because I looked down I'm
like I shave my legs a couple of weeks
ago and now I'm like fully hairy I'm
like I have to shave my legs again this
is the price I pay for having you know
gorgeous follicles no I would say anyone
who's shaving every few weeks oh sorry a
few days oh okay no like three days and
my hairs are back to being fully grown
on my legs yeah it's so annoying it's so
annoying it never ends and like if I
have my armpits lasered and it was one
of the best things I ever did because it
totally truly works but the surface area
of lasering my armpits is 1 100th of the
surface area of my legs especially if
I'm doing my thighs so it's just so
tedious and so painful like there has to
be a better way yeah
lasering my upper lip perfect it's a
small piece of skin my armpit's perfect
my legs so my legs first of all are huge
it's a lot of time energy pain and
there's like no better way no
I sure as [ __ ] not gonna wax my legs
I just think that's insane no and I've
like waxed my legs a few times and I
didn't even find it to be that effective
like all the like the hairs grow in
different directions maybe because I've
shaved for so long that like it doesn't
it wasn't even really that smooth after
yeah they're like the hair removal
industry needs to evolve I feel like
we've been stuck with the same options
for a while like tweezing threading
waxing lasering you could Nair that's
pretty new technology
so smelly and weird and unnatural I
don't know something about it freaks me
out yeah no it's like Chernobyl it's
like toxic why don't I just take a torch
a flame torch what's it called a
flamethrower and torch the hair on my
legs Nair seems very Kem and I'm not
even like you know clean beauty girl
like I don't care what the [ __ ] is in my
lipstick but Nair crosses a line it's
[ __ ] toxic have you smelled it no I
know it's giving Chernobyl it smells
like Chernobyl
so I just feel like you know the hair
removal industry has gotten comfortable
with the options and I think they need
to continue evolving maybe a pill
ow
right and I like the hair growth on my
head and that's it
everywhere below my head bald please
maybe a pill that stops hair growth but
with an accompanying serum that you put
in your scalp to nullify counteract to
nullify the effects on the scalp yeah I
like that get to work me yeah figure it
out formulate scientific toasters free
idea go patent it yeah I'll be your
number one customer yeah we'll do ads
for free for free
um so I wasn't burden yourselves if you
guys want to write in and have us change
your lives unburdenyourselves at
gmail.com that is our show we are well
over an hour and a half we I have to be
so badly like I've been in pain for the
last 30 minutes thank you guys so much
for listening to the morning morning
show where we deliver the past five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
we're watching this on YouTube please
don't forget to subscribe give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast with a podcast we found on
Spotify
goodbye everyone have a great day we'll
see you tomorrow tomorrow I love you
tomorrow bye